today's topic gina carano so if you
aren't aware gina carano
is a x-mix martial art artist
as well as one of the actresses from the
tv show
uh the mandalorian on disney and x-men
deadpool and recently she was let go by
disney from uh the mandalorian for
tweets
she made what you mean tweets i just
said that because you don't like to say
tweets
now you achieved so if you guys want to
know what's that in those messages you
gotta go for a tweet bruh
basically she made uh she made a
comparison saying the way that we're
treating
people who uh are right wing or who
believe in the right
um you know as long as we keep doing
stuff like this it may lead to a lot of
the same things that happened to
uh in germany now a lot of people got
upset about this
and uh made us think about it disney got
upset and decided to just
fire her and everyone's talking about it
now that i've kind of paraphrased i'll
put the the messages up
you can't use that word i can't stand
that word
who got the keys to my dream is this an
attack on free speech i think
i think not by the little definition not
by the literal definition but i do think
it is bad
um for public discourse the problem
doesn't lie in the fact that they fight
her
the problem lies in the fact that they
apply these rules unevenly think every
company
every enemy is allowed to deter
determine what kind of speech they find
defensible or not but when the lead star
of the exact same tv show pedro pascal
who is also on the mandalorian who is
the mandalorian when he makes
a reference to what the jews suffered uh
but this time it's a it's about the kids
being locked up at the border
that's sanctioned that's fine but then
when the other side
you know the more right-wing leaning
side does a similar
reference that's unacceptable and
i think what people generally have an
issue with is what they feel like
when liberals get to express themselves
it's seen as acceptable
by the media therefore it's greenlit
but then when the opposite aisle
expresses themselves on public
platforms they lose their job and
there's a resentment that builds from
that over time i won't even get into the
fact that disney
just loves you know hollywood in general
loves to virtue signal you know
where they'll say you guys can't make
references to you know these internment
camps meanwhile
they're making deals with china who got
ugers locked up in present-day
internment camps
weren't they filming next to account so
when you know this stuff
it's it makes it makes it extra
distasteful
when they pretend to be virtuous right a
bit like a yoga
a yoga uh model exactly so there's that
element there that kind of rubs you the
wrong way
i think this is just it's just bad for
public discourse
in the in a time where people are so
fractured on opposite ends of the
spectrum
and they just yell at the other end of
the aisle you don't bridge that gap by
saying this speech is now unacceptable
everything that leans right you're going
to lose your job in the arts
well then what happens to the artistic
world where the only people who get to
speak and share their opinions are that
of a liberal mindset
and if you're right-leaning well you
can't join the arts or if you want to
join keep your mouth shut
do you think that's a good thing aren't
you doing the same thing that you're
fighting against
you know do you really think that's a
good thing so i think that's what i
question i don't think this is a wise
decision but
they have the right to but just because
they have the right to exercise it
doesn't mean i think it's a good thing
nor does it mean i respect it
but it does seem uneven it does seem
like if you lean right and you're saying
stuff on these public platforms there's
a possibility that's just the way i
perceive it
now my perception may be off but it
feels like a lot of other people
perceive it that way and i do
think that most of us would agree that
hollywood that the arts
and that general mainstream media has a
very left-leaning
you know even social media platforms
have a very left-leaning
um stance and when it comes to
matters of censorship or matters of like
shutting people down
it seems like the right definitely gets
the brunt of it that's just been my
perception from afar
and i think that's just bad for public
discourse discourse even if i don't
agree
with the opinions that they're exposing
i do think they should be able to
say those things uh without fearing like
that their job is going to be lost
tomorrow so
uh what were your thoughts when you saw
did you feel like um this
was free speech being threatened
or being hurt i think it's the whole the
same thing that goes on over and over
again
um basically
she had the right to say it disney had
the right to do what they did
is it dangerous or is it is it
potentially uh
i'm looking at it and i'm like
was what she said that bad but then
again
you know there's a certain group of
people that are kind of untouchable
that's the thing
don't name them they who shall not be
named no no i'm not going to name them
they're inductable harry potter
baltimore exactly
tommy riddle in this what the hell is
wrong with you
i name a name but there are people that
are untouchable
there are people that whether it was
what you said was right or wrong it's
not even no longer a matter of that
it's whether they like what you said or
no there's a a lot of people there's
groups of people like that
right that are untouchable as a matter
of fact it makes me think of a joke on
one of my friends did
about those untouchable people and he
made a joke about people that you cannot
you could not joke about and he joked
about them
and now he's in court so he was talking
about something that was real
in the form of a joke and he's in court
over a joke that's gonna potentially
cost him hundreds of thousands of
dollars
right now you know what i mean that's
where we're at right now whether you win
we
wins or lo or lose that money is spent
all right so basically it proves your
point
it proves the point of the person you're
trying to you you try to cancel
and i'm saying i agree with all the
tweets i'm not saying i agree with the
person or whatever what not i'm just
saying
it could potentially harm people yeah
it's potentially dangerous
there's groups that you can't you can't
touch can't touch this
can't touch this it proves the point
that you can't touch these people
but anyways they have the the right
to do it it's their brand they do what
they want
i think it's a bit extreme but
it's at their discretion every time we
brought someone we bring something up
and we say something is at the
discretion of someone
there's no parameters really there's no
really parameter is it just really at
the discretion
of the people on top to do whatever they
want to do and they
don't no longer want to associate with
you they can do that
people have been doing that it's just
like the testy with that other youtuber
you're losing your job over something
that you did in your privacy in your
house and
but it gets exposed that's where we're
at right now
wrong or not it's potentially dangerous
yeah
i believe it i don't personally like
when people make comparisons to slavery
or people make comparisons to you know
what the jews had to deal deal with but
i still think i don't know i don't think
you should be fired for that
but i don't make the decisions i just
don't like that they were such
hypocrites about it
it's hard to feel like it's fair it's
like when you your parents
beat you for something that your sister
did yeah it's the exact same way
it's hard to have it's hard to look at
that i got your parents and be like
okay you're the person that teaches me
that that's a decision that you you're
doing you had
all the information yeah but it's me
that i get the beating after that you're
gonna look your parents a certain type
of way yeah that's the best way i could
put it yeah i agree with that
and the thing is if i'd have to say the
people that are left-leaning and
everything and stuff
you're giving ammunition to the people
from the right you're creating martyrs
by doing that that's not good for you
you give them you say no it's not like
that but then you proceed to
show them how it is like that how it is
how they say it
i don't consider myself right leaning
but i can see
why they think the way they think and
how you're giving them ammunition
it's almost like if they're right you're
proving them right
every step you're doing like that yeah
let's cancel this let's cancel that
let's cancel that and they're talking
about saying well you're censoring
everything
we're not censoring we're not but you
can't talk
dude and all this time you were fighting
because your voice needed what do you
talk about you can talk
but you're going to lose your job yeah
you're going to lose your job and you
know
me not being able to talk come on now
that's just semantics we're not
let's play on words come on now you know
what i mean it's just
it's just they're right and people are
right you're making them right
and you're doing the same you're using
the same tactics that they're using
that's crazy whatever well tell us what
you guys think in the comments below
foreign